whoa oh it's the people's champ
damn can you hear us
y'all can hear y'all can i hear me yeah
yeah
big dog i got my beats my beats in so i
don't know if it's a delay or not let me
know for the delay i'll take them out
on the regular audio sounds great it
sounds good good
man okay thanks for joining us what's
going on in unh
town or what yeah and h town right now
dry we barely miss the hurricane man but
we praying for those who got hit
hey man man yeah it was bad out there
huh
yeah man man it's crazy when you see
like the before and after devastation
pick
man it's crazy and what do y'all do to
hunker down do y'all do anything to
hunker down do you have a plan these
days because that's a regular pattern of
behavior over there
yeah man right now it's just uh you know
get your stuff together like
food or supplies stuff but you know you
know how i go
we get we get uh stocked up and have a
party that that first night the second
night we
all out all we just cooked all the food
drunk all the beer
[Laughter]
man the hardest part is just like you
know just like kobe just
staying put you know what i'm saying uh
or or evacuating if you
but the thing is nowadays with so much
like uh you know
uh subdivisions and things being uh
built that the flood patterns change so
areas that used to not flood now they
flood because things
have been built so but when they give
that they give that uh their word to
evacuate boy better hit that road
[Laughter]
yeah some people you guys got the few
people like nah i'm just gonna stay here
and bunker down
and it never works out for him ever paul
can you give me what do you feel like is
happening with music during the uh
during the covet times like do you feel
like we're gonna catch any type of new
you know like vibes or anything that's
going to come out of this
or are you seeing any of that are you
seeing anybody really kind of find their
own lane with this thing or are you
noticing anything what's
what's up yeah no doubt it's been a big
shift in terms of the creation of the
art of music you know
it was a steady pattern of you know
the way to make music put it out there
sell music the way we consume music all
of that the way we performed as artists
and as fans how we
received it you know it was just a a few
different names but it was
you know just one freeway going in one
direction but now with kobe that just
opened things up completely it just uh
it kind of opened uh the the floodgates
you know i'm saying just
for all different types because it's
you're not like restricted to whatever
the
the way the means is you know you can
whatever the trend of fat is you can go
outside of that now
that actually is the time for
non-traditional ways of creating the
music and putting the music like all the
things i said performing at everything
so
you know it's just uh it's been an
inspiring time of your artist
it's been a scrambling time if you're an
executive or somebody who's like
more of a traditional sense of well how
are we going to put out i mean how we're
going to do it now that things
change um but for me i i've appreciated
the fact that
you know it's uh it's it's less
restricted i think you know where
you can try new things that's where i
came from anyway to underground or
you know more where's more raw you know
what i'm saying so now you can kind of
be raw with it because it's an
experimental type of time
you know so there's definitely a lot of
artists out there and also
previous to kovy everybody was you know
busy doing things on the road on tour
whatever got family all of the above
working on new albums doing
extracurricular things outside of music
everything so
now it's like everybody's stuck at home
so where you know we might
previously i might have been extremely
busy now i got time to do songs with
other artists collaborating vice versa
it's musically artistically it's so
definitely a a
a kind of [ __ ] a big shift right now are
you all ready are you are you a fan of
like the the tick tock
uh hooks and stuff like that like the
kids getting the the riffs from tick
tock and then making a full
kind of song i guess yeah
me personally i mean i'm kind of more
traditional but i'm not against it you
know i'm saying oh
my preference is just more traditional
but you know it's just
with all of the different means of
social media everything is just
it's just more tools you know more tools
you have you know it's
it's like it's like of a you know van
gogh's painting and all of a sudden
there's a new color
that got invented you know i'm saying
it's like so you can either choose to
use it or choose not to and
you know what i'm saying is it's
definitely that's the newer way if you
want to connect with a like
a lot of people say younger audience but
there's old people on tick tock too you
know what i'm saying
like seals on there steel's on there
yeah
paula one thing i noticed about you man
you always stay in such uh
your vibe is always just so positive man
where does some of that energy come from
and has it always been like that was it
was it like that when you were first
kind of starting out or is that
something you've kind of embraced as
you've gone along
man i've always just been grateful for
the opportunity to do what i love to do
you know and i've never once
taken that for granted um it's something
that
this thing i paid hard for work hard for
still work hard pray hard for
it's just to be able to do my dream my
childhood dream to do music you know
what i'm saying so to
be able to have that as a career i don't
take it you know lightly
a lot of people when you know a lot of
times when you become a
not a doctor or a lawyer or a teacher or
something that you can kind of go to
school
for get a degree and get a job or just
it don't even have to be dr lloyd but
any traditional job
you know if you do something outside of
that be it athletics entertainment music
acting you know anything like that you
know it's a
it's a different sense you know what i'm
saying it's it's a hard work ethic but
when you have a a traditional job you
always got people you got to ask them to
you always got to be on time
if you slip up one day you could be
fired if you come to work
late one day you could be probably
wearing entertainment so you know it's
demanding but it's a lot
more relaxed i think but i kind of try
to always take
that professional attitude of man i got
to be on time i gotta you know take this
serious although i might be smoking or
drinking or having fun as well i'm
really you know that sometimes that's
more to relax my mind so that i can
focus in other areas you know i'm saying
but i i don't take it for granted man i
love my job or just to be able to just
do what i love to do man i love it
you've lost a lot of weight paul could
used to be a kind of a thick boy back
maybe you're sipping on that lean which
i'm dying to try yeah
for reals dog i can't wait to get my
lips around some lean but
uh what'd you do get on a bike how'd you
lose all the weight man yeah you used to
be a little more wall
heavy on the wall a little less paul
[Laughter]
yeah man we did a whole lifestyle
transformation me and my wife man
i tried all types of things but
definitely i will say man you know the
partying type of lifestyle it affected
my metabolism other things so
when i'm working out eight hours a day
you know what i'm saying running five or
six miles a day on the treadmill at the
park all
types of man even when i'm eating only
fishing
playing white rice with no seasoning i
wouldn't lose no weight so i had surgery
i had a
surgery called the gastric sleeve it's
man it saved my life i was uh i was over
320
i was working up 350. man when i when i
got it get that boy a bike
right yeah yeah i need to be born on a
bike
riding with you right what to do
what to so paul i see you also working
with some of these jewelry boys out
there man i see you and uh
johnny out there uh tell us about do you
guys have a a partnership you guys seem
like you guys are
are grilling everybody along the south
coast these days yeah and
you guys sent me a pair of uh bottom
grills which i forgot today because i
have cte but i appreciate it man
yes sir man that's my boy johnny man
you know we've been doing it now for
over 20 years man working together
he started off doing jury repair he came
here as a
immigrant from vietnam man he got a hell
of a american story man this is a true
american dream
he got family members who were refugees
in the war in the vietnam war you know
they were down with the american side
america gave him refuge
man his family came over here one by one
and they they
a lot of them said not all over a lot of
more in the jewelry business as well and
it's a true story of entrepreneurship
man he came over here doing just jury
repair working out of his
garage the first six months he was there
he didn't he made i think like
fifty dollars or something some
ridiculous thing to him that was like a
million dollars
so he really enjoyed it and appreciated
it the opportunity he had and
that's why we both had the same type of
spirit of just
joy and we love what we do man and um
you know he started off doing jewelry
repair
and making jury as a whole salesman for
the retailers
so he also has a different perspective
on the clientele so
that's how i teamed up with him i was
doing grills out of my trunk you know
and working out at different stores
hustling grills it was something i
teamed up with somebody to do they came
down from new york
and taught me how to do it and then from
there they brought me to johnny johnny
was the one actually making the grill
and this was around 1998 and at that
time you know it was uh
what we what i would see when i'm going
to put in my order for grills is this
what this is what would be difficult
it'd be multi-racial people as customers
but a lot of them from the hood
so it wasn't like proper english being
spoke which was
what was taught to johnny property so
johnny would be in there as a vietnamese
immigrant
in broken english and it would be all
type of races in there
speaking non-traditional english would
be in there
i would be like the translator
and eventually it would be like you know
as my rap career kind of
ascended people would be in there like
you paul yeah
okay and then johnny would be like damn
man you fans there man we got a team
really did man it really helped my
career in music as well because
you know i could get to a lot of people
who i i could maybe do music with
that you know wanted a grill you know
that would be my introduction they
wouldn't do your girl that's why i you
know
you know a lot of people man you know
just you know doing grills for them and
then next thing you know we're doing
songs together
well and that's such a good note i
noticed a lot of
one way to get into any business is find
a way to be of service at first to the
people that are already in the business
you know
find a way to contribute and it's
amazing that the the stairways you can
make from that first step
yeah that's something we lean on to with
the jury and my music career like for my
music
i've never once ever missed the show
never missed a flight
ever never been late you know ever i was
always talk you know if you're 15
minutes early then you're on time
if you're on time you're late and if
you're late it's unacceptable this is
how i was always taught so i always make
sure i'm
so my music career goes that way as well
as you know
you know the jury business well you know
it's all about the customer
it's a hustle business so if somebody
comes in there with a lot of money you
might not necessarily
if you come in there you might say give
me a give me a grill and you might not
know what a typical grill goes for but i
know you got money
and i know you want something nice so
it's certain ways i can word it
to make you feel like okay yeah i gotta
spend twenty thirty thousand on the
grill when you might only want a 500
grill you know what i'm saying so it's
definitely a hustle game
we me and johnny though we stand on our
morals and principles so
you know it's something where we're
trying to sell you jewelry and you're
going to bring your you
when it's mother's day you're going to
buy your you know your mama or your
mother-in-law
you know on valentine's day you know all
these type of occasions you might bring
your son in to get his first starter set
of a chain you know he might bring his
kids in so we really look at it as like
you know we ain't going nowhere so we
gonna treat the people that are our
customers we're gonna treat them right
because we want them to stand on what
they buy you know they
we real about it gang man already and i
feel like grills are kind of they're
kind of mainstream now you see everybody
rocking the
grills drake i mean you name it dave
chappelle's been seen with grills like
it now it's pretty mainstream doug
yeah man it definitely has gone
mainstream what's the most expensive
grill you guys have ever put together i
know that's
you know is there a is there somebody
that came in that just wanted it all you
know they wanted damn
just full zai or whatever it's gonna be
cheap
yeah kanye's were like about twenty
thousand i think he i had some that were
up there
uh i think the most expensive were the
ones we did for quavo
recently uh for you know it kind of
varies because
and sometimes it's by design you know if
you von miller when they won the super
bowl he came in was like i don't care
what you tell me the price tag is i'm
paying it so
he's not lacking in the money department
so he's not he ain't tripping on what he
got to pay
but every now and then you know there
will be like a new type of setting
it's something johnny came up with
called invisible set baguette
where you you uh set the bag at diamonds
by hand
real close to each other and they it's
like a wall of diamonds with baguette
diamonds actually i got this visual set
on my bottom right here
damn well you can hell a taxi man you
could just smile and hell a cab
man but when the invisible set came out
those were the most expensive and
johnny did his own all invisible step
back yet for his was like
80 000 or something crazy but i think
cuevos are
the most expensive right now at the time
yeah and what what's up with that whip
in the back there i'll see it's a green
screen but you still you still under the
whips
yeah that's my uh that's my slab my uh
my cadillac right there let me i got a
few others man
i'm big in the cadillacs i definitely
like the uh
i like the old school look but uh you
know the new school this new
this new ct6 is my favorite right here
this one i'm pushing right now with
detecting wire wheels on it
you know what i'm saying damn right slow
down
damn that's beautiful man well paul you
know we're big fans here man and we just
appreciate it man we appreciate you
spending some time with us man that's
really beautiful yeah we love you man
hey i love y'all too man we've been
watching out all the time me and my wife
the fam you know a lot of my partners
too man we always tuned in to the king
and stink man you know what i'm saying
gang gang
well look we'll put a link and stuff too
if any of our you know our listeners
want to get uh
get that grilled out get grilled up man
yeah yeah
baby project about to drive too man i
got this project right here in the back
it's called slope culture is getting
ready to drop
october 14th let me shout that out one
time that's sub culture
yes sir and what is it
it's a new album i got i worked i got
down with red bull studios they got a
studio over there in santa monica
all top of the line i got down with some
some of the top producers and
songwriters and we just went in man we
went in for a couple weeks right before
kobe did
actually i'm flying back from la to
houston in the midst of
right when all the kobe they debating
whether or not is you know real or is it
gonna hit us
right right then they both shut it down
oh they actually shut it down on my
birthday march 11th that's when
the nba shut down all kind of stuff shut
down man so uh
yeah but uh we we got this in right here
the subculture we worked it out right
before kobe had hit
and uh you know what i'm saying we're
getting ready to drop it october 14th
congrats yeah congrats well after yeah
we'll have to run one of the tracks on
here too man we'll get set up with your
people so we can run it on here and uh
and flirt the album for you thanks so
much paul for your time i appreciate you
man
are you going to be in l.a anytime soon
or have you sit in the culture corner
yeah man i've been wanting to come on
now man i know [ __ ] asked me a while
back i really been nick i'll be putting
it off man i know he probably like
he won't respond but i really was
blowing it off trying to wait till i
could come in personally i really want
i definitely want to come [ __ ] with
y'all man
i gotta wrap that up with some grills
yeah
yeah well look you're always welcome
here paul man you guys have a beautiful
day over there in houston man
hey for sure man yes sir yes appreciate
man
take care brother all right be good
thanks hey hey phil i got to give you an
lsu shout out for my boy alice bradman
oh yeah man you ready for it huh yes sir
yes sir
i appreciate that man yeah i'm up to i'm
about to keep tabs on him man it's going
is houston playing houston you guys are
playing right
yeah right now we were playing uh aids
yesterday but uh they
they shut it down because somebody on
the edge sets a positive for kobe and
alex
he's been hurt but i think he's about to
come back next week or a couple weeks
and say
dang man well i appreciate the uh i
appreciate the sharing the news man
um you guys be well over there paul
what's up man thank you all for having
me take care man
all right bye dang that's awesome
let's give it up for nick for getting
paul yeah all
thank you thank you nick's picks it's
easy when they're a fan
that's awesome that he watches i thought
for sure you're gonna hit him with the
verse
chappelle did you get the verse ready
what is it this is the one i wrapped
just give it to him let's just yeah
he'll be watching
get one more time you want to give him
the beat nick or what
which which oh you want me to wrap the
verse yeah
yeah we want that man why do you want to
rub because what's up
no not a little
you can watch it on brenda's instagram
that's another thing it goes hard on
that you can bring that up nick it's a
good way to
celebrate paul wall yeah damn so cool
dude his
his cars are dope he's a great ass dude
yeah real cool
he's just so positive he's such a nice
dude i don't know he got the
the people's champ the tummy tuck
yeah man he said he was gonna die he was
three fifty man three
fifty three third he said he was he was
climbing like the damn tesla stopped
what's the biggest you been brendan
uh go i've been 270. that's the biggest
yeah
damn here it is sheesh
is that me
now going wild huh
[Music]
oh
it looks like timber and pumbaa huh
yeah that's you guys dog yeah look at
her right here
[Laughter]
sideways too much
damn brittany you should be one of those
people that picks out uh
criminals bruh i don't know go to the
thing say who did it
he looked like morgan freeman and they'd
be like damn like damn that all right
they sketch it out
gang man that could be you you could be
me you
you have so many careers man yeah man
you're doing him bro
oh wow what a great guest